YURI: Hi, everyone.
My name is Yuri.
And today, I'm
going to be talking
to you about tf.data, which is
TensorFlow's input pipeline.
As a disclaimer,
this presentation
assumes familiarity with
basic TensorFlow concepts
such as ops and kernels.
And it contains a
lot of code examples
that are not necessarily
100% accurate.
There may be some details
that have been removed
because they're either
unnecessary or distracting
for the purpose of presentation.
So with that, let's get started.
In this talk, we're going
to cover a couple of topics.
We're going to peel
the two main layers
of tf.data's
implementation one by one,
first focusing on Python
view and then on the C++ view
of tf.data.
And then I'm going to cover
three areas of tf.data that
might be of interest to
the broader audience,
support for non-tensor types,
and both static and dynamic
optimizations in tf.data.
So let's get started
with the Python view.
Throughout the course
of the presentation,
I'm going to be using the
following example, which
is a pretty standard example
of an input pipeline.
What this input
pipeline does, it's
reading files that are
in TFRecord formats--
so this contains records--
then shuffling those records,
applying a map transformation
that allows you to transform
the records and parse them,
pre-process them, and finally,
batching the pre-processed data
so that it's amenable to
machine learning computation.
And the idiomatic way to
iterate through elements
of an input pipeline in TF
2.0 is by a simple for loop.
And that's because in TF 2.0,
data sets are Python iterables.
Besides this
approach, you can also
use the explicit iter
or next keywords.
Now, as the comment at
the bottom mentions,
the user-defined
function that you
can pass into the
map transformation
can be both graph or
non-graph computation
where the non-graph computation
is enabled by AutoGraph.
And I'll talk a little
more about that later on.
Just to contrast the
simplifications that happened
in the transition
between 1.x and 2.0,
let's take a look at
what an input pipeline--
or idiomatic iteration of
an input pipeline-- in 1.x
would look like.
And you can see that the
definition of the input
pipeline that is the top part of
the data set remains the same.
But the iteration is
much more verbose.
So hopefully, this kind of
illustrates that the simplest
way to iterate
through a data set
has been made much more
simple in the 2.0 release
of TensorFlow.
So let's talk a bit more about
what's actually going on when
you run the Python program.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to go through different
lines of the Python program
and talk about what actually
happens under the hood in terms
of what types of TensorFlow ops
these invocations correspond
to.
And I'm using a
diagram to visualize
the different types of ops.
The gray box is
the actual op-- so
in this case, TFRecordDataset--
while the yellow boxes
are the different
inputs for the op,
while the blue box is
the output of the op.
So in the case of
the TFRecordDataset,
we have a couple of inputs--
file names, compression types,
buffer sizes.
And an important thing that
I want to highlight here
is that this op produces
a variant tensor, which
is a representation
of the data set object
that can be passed
between different ops.
And we will see how that's used
right away when we're looking
at the map transformation.
So the MapDataset op, you can
see that one of its inputs
is actually a variant, which
is the downstream data set that
produces the elements that the
map transformation transforms.
Other inputs are-- they're
called other arguments.
And these are actually
the captured inputs
for the function.
In this particular
case, that input
would be empty, because
the function doesn't
have any captured inputs,
at least not as outlined
in the example.
And the round boxes
are not inputs.
They are attributes.
The difference between
inputs and attributes
is that the attribute
values do not
change with different
executions of the op.
They are constant.
And the attributes
here are function,
which identifies the
function parse, which
is stored separately
in TensorFlow runtime--
but it allows the op to look
it up when it executes--
as well as the type
of the arguments
that the function inputs.
And again, like the
TFRecordDataset,
it produces an output variant.
So a little more about
the use of support
for user-defined
functions in tf.data.
A number of tf.data
transformations
are operations that
actually allow users
to specify their own functions.
Examples of those are filter,
flat_map, interleave, map,
or reduce.
And irrespective of the
mode of the execution,
tf.data will convert the
user-defined function
into a graph.
And as illustrated on
the previous slide,
the function graph is--
a handle to the function graph
is passed to the respective op
through an attr.
A little more detail on the
tracing implementation-- it
was originally based on
framework.function.Defun
and recently switched to the
same tracing implementation
that's used for TF
functions in 2.0.
This provided a
number of benefits,
including control
flow version 2,
support for resource variables,
TensorArrayV2, and also
the ability for users to specify
user-defined functions that
are not necessarily
graph-compatible as
long as they're
supported by AutoGraph.
And it's marked as
work in progress
here because this
functionality is actually
temporarily disabled.
And we're working on enabling
it back on very soon.
So to tie it together, if we
look at the input pipeline
definition, the four lines, this
definition of an input pipeline
will roughly correspond to
the following ops, and inputs,
and attributes.
Now, up to this
point, we've only
talked about how to
define the input pipeline.
But naturally,
the thing that you
would want to do with
the input pipeline
is that you would like
to enumerate the elements
inside of it.
And that's where the
iterator ops come in play.
Because iterator,
it can be thought
of as an instance of a
data set that has a state
and allows you to enumerate the
elements in a sequential order.
So what are the
iterator lifecycle ops?
The op on the left
top corner called
Iterator that takes no input and
produces a single output called
handle is an op that creates an
empty iterator resource, which
is a way to pass the
state, iterator state,
between different operations,
while the MakeIterator op takes
two different inputs.
It takes iterator resource,
which is something
that we've created
by the iterator op,
and a data set variant.
And what this
MakeIterator op does,
it instantiates the
data set-- sorry,
the iterator resource with
that particular data set.
So at that point, you
have an iterator resource
that has been initialized
to start producing
elements for that particular
data set as defined by the data
set variant.
Now, the actual
iteration happens
by the means of the
IteratorGetNext op,
which takes an iterator
resource handle
and produces the
actual elements, which
can be a tensor, or a nest
of tensors, or possibly
also non-tensor types.
And later in the
presentation, I'll
talk about what
exactly is supported
in tf.data in terms of types.
And finally, there's
also a DeleteIterator op
that takes the iterator
resource and makes
sure that the iterator
state is properly
disposed of when the
iterator is no longer needed.
This final op, as
you can imagine,
is very important to make sure
that iterator resources are not
being left behind.
Because it is not uncommon
for the iterator resource
state to amass hundreds
of megabytes or gigabytes
of memory.
And leaving these around can
result in your computation
running out of memory.
As a side note, when you're
looking at the performance
or profiling performance of
your program or input pipeline,
you will see IteratorGetNext
op in something
like a timeline, or an
[INAUDIBLE],, or CPU profile
trace.
And this is the op that
indicates the output
latency of your input pipeline.
And so if that op is very
small in its runtime--
I would say on the
order of microseconds--
it means that your input
pipeline is not a bottleneck.
And if it's larger
than that, chances
are you are bottlenecked by
input, at least to some extent.
So now that we've talked
about the different ops, let's
actually see how the execution
of the Python program
corresponds or maps to the
execution-- or creation
and execution-- of
the different ops.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to contrast the TF 2.0
eager mode style of execution
with the TF 1.x graph mode
style of execution to help
folks understand what are
the differences between TF--
between the two modes as
far as tf.data is concerned.
So let's start with
the 2.0 eager mode.
In eager mode, ops are
created and executed
as the program runs.
So when the Python line that
creates the TFRecodrDataset()
runs, we end up creating--
both creating and executing--
the RFRecordDataset() op.
And similarly,
with the next line,
we create and execute the
shuffle() data set op,
feeding the output of the
previous op inside of it
as part of the input variant.
That way, we tie-- we're
starting to build the input
pipeline, trying it to--
connecting the two
stages together.
When the .map
transformation is executed,
the user-defined function
is traced and stored
in the TensorFlow runtime.
And a handle to it is
passed, as an attribute,
to the map data set op
along with the input variant
representing the input
pipeline up to that point.
And finally, the batch()
op is created and executed,
creating the final stage
of the input pipeline.
Now, when the idiomatic way of
iterating through tf.data is
used-- that is, the for loop
for element in data set--
what happens under the hood
is that an entire method is
called on the data set object.
And that actually triggers
the creation and execution
of two ops.
We first create the iterator
resource through an op.
It's called Anonymous Iterator.
And I'm going to point out
the difference between that
and the iterator as I talk
about the graph more execution.
And then we associate
the iterator resource
with the input pipeline
that we've created
via the MakeIterator op.
And as the Python
for loop iterates,
we end up invoking next() on
the Python iterator object.
And this translates to
the IteratorGetNext op
being created and
subsequently executed.
It's only created once, and
it's executed as many times
as there's elements
in the data set.
And finally, when the Python
iterator object goes out
of scope, the DeleteIterator
op is invoked,
which makes sure that the
iterator state, iterator
resource state, is
properly disposed of.
So let's contrast
that with how this
would work in 1.x graph mode.
So in graph mode, the
execution happens lazily,
which means we create the ops
as the Python lines are invoked.
But they're not executed--
the execution is postponed
until the particular ops are
run using decision mechanism.
So just stepping
through the program,
we see that we are building
a graph but not executing it.
There is a particular mechanism
for creating the iterator
resource op and the
MakeIterator op,
as well as creating the op that
is later used for iteration.
And it's only within the
run part of your program
that ops are executed.
When the iterator
initializer op is executed,
we actually end up executing
the entire graph of the input
pipeline, including
the iterator op.
Now, the difference
between the iterator op
and the anonymous iterator op
that was used in the eager mode
is that anonymous iterator
op creates a new resource
every time it's executed,
while iterator op creates
a resource only the
first time it's executed.
And any subsequent
execution returns a handle
to that resource.
And the reason for that is
when we run the get_next op,
that get_next op will actually
execute the iterator op as well
by the nature of the
difference between the graph
mode and eager mode executions.
And so that's kind of an
artifact of graph mode
execution.
And thus we need different
types of resource creation
ops for eager mode and graph
mode inside of tf.data.
And there is no explicit
delete iterator op.
And that's because
the iterator resource
lifetime is tied to the lifetime
of the surrounding session.
And so when the
session is destroyed,
so is the iterator resource.
So far, so good?
OK.
So let's now, after--
now that we've kind of
peeled the Python layer,
and we talked about an op-level
view of tf.data, let's dive
a level deeper.
And let's talk
about what actually
happens inside of the kernels
that implement these ops.
And like with most other
TensorFlow op kernels,
these are implemented in C++.
So before we retrace our steps
or take a look at the example
program from a
C++ point of view,
let's talk about what are
the important tf.data C++
abstractions.
So the top-level one is a
data set op kernel which
implements the op kernel API.
And this provides a mechanism
for implementing different
types of data set ops through
a single interface where
the different implementations
of the data set op kernel
interface just need to override
or implement the MakeDataset()
method.
What the MakeDataset() does, it
returns a DatasetBase object.
Now, the purpose of the data
set op kernel is to provide
a translation between a graph
representation of the op
and a C++ representation
of the op.
Now the data set object--
DatasetBase object-- in turn
has a method for creating
an iterator for that particular
data set as well as a method
called AsGraphDef(), which
provides the reverse of what I
just talked about, which allows
you to basically go from a C++
representation of a data set
back to a graph representation
of a data set, which will come
in handy when I talk about
static optimizations of tf.data.
The MakeIterator() method
of the DatasetBase returns
an IteratorBase, which is
an interface representing
the different types
of iterators we have.
And the single most important
method in that interface is
GetNext(), which is the actual
C++ method used for iterating
through the state of
the input pipeline.
And coupled with that
is the IteratorResource,
which holds the state.
And so as we will see, the
IteratorResource is actually
the entry point into
the connected structure
of different C++ iterators
through which ops like
IteratorGetNext
get receive data.
And the SetIteratorFromDataset()
method corresponds
to the MakeIterator op,
as we'll shortly see.
Last but not least, tf.data
has two C++ abstractions
for representing functions,
its CapturedFunction
and
InstantiatedCapturedFunction.
The CapturedFunction
provides a mechanism
for bundling a function
with its captured inputs
and later instantiating it.
And the
InstantiateCapturedFunction
provides tf.data with a
mechanism to actually run
the user-defined functions.
And so you can
perhaps see how there
is a simple relationship between
DatasetBase and IteratorBase
and CapturedFunction and
InstantiatedCapturedFunction
where the letter is an
instance of the former in both
of those cases.
All right, so let's go
back to our example.
And now we're going to take a
look at what happens when we
execute the different lines
of the input pipeline,
but what happens
in the C++ world.
And unlike in the previous
Python view section,
in this section, the diagram
at the bottom will not be graph
objects, but they
will be C++ objects.
So in this case, the
TFRecord Data set down below
is actually an instance
of the TFRecord Data set
that's of type DatasetBase.
And for context, we are,
again, in TF 2.0 eager mode.
So when the Python program
executes a tf.data TFRecord
Data set with files argument,
we end up creating the data set
variant through the
following C++ code.
And just for illustration,
I'm showing here
how that op kernel fetches
the set of file names.
And the set of file
names can either
be a single string
or a list of strings.
So there is some
subsequent string parsing
that's elided here.
But the important bit
here is that we're then
storing the TFRecord Data set
op data set in the output, where
the data set object
itself is a variant, which
allows us to pass it on
as an input to another op.
And that another op is the
ShuffleDataset, which gets
executed immediately after.
And so here I'm illustrating
how the op receives
or kind of extracts the variant
tensor input from the op kernel
context and then passes it
inside of the ShuffleDatasetOp
so that the ShuffleDatasetOp
now understands
what stage is producing
elements for it to consume.
Next, it's the map
transformation.
What I want to illustrate here
is how the CapturedFunction
mechanism works.
We use the CapturedFunction
Create factory
that takes the identifier
of the function, which
is a list of
attributes, as well as
any captured inputs if there
were any stored in the op
kernel context.
And similar to the
ShuffleDatasetOp,
we end up passing the captured
function as well as the input
to the downstream data set
inside of the constructor.
And finally, there is
not much new to see here
for the BatchDatasetOp.
So I pretty much elided all
the details from this slide.
OK, so now for the
interesting stuff,
because this is where
we are going to start
iterating through the data set.
So the first thing that
happens when you call--
or when you write "for
element in dataset"--
under the hood,
this gets translated
to a Python iter invocation
on the data set object.
And the first thing
that happens is
that we create the
anonymous Iterator Resource.
And here is just an illustration
of the actual mechanism that
does this as well as the
code that then produces
the handle to the iterator.
And this handle, along
with the variant tensor
representing the
batch data set is then
passed to the MakeIteratorOp.
So here you can see how we
extract both the data set
variant as well as the resource
handle and use these two
to pass them into the
SetIteratorFromDataset() method
that, as we will shortly see,
will, in a cascading fashion,
create a sequence of
connected iterator objects.
So let's take a closer look at
what SetIteratorFromDataset()
does.
It takes a look at the
outermost data set,
because that's the
variant that it received.
And it invokes MakeIterator
on that particular data set.
And this will prompt a creation
of a Batch Iterator using
the MakeIterator() method
on the Batch Data set,
but also trigger a recursive
MakeIterator() invocation
on the input of Batch Data
set, which is Map Data set.
And so in that fashion, the
Map-- in a similar fashion,
Map Iterator is created,
where the Map Iterator
creator will also instantiate
the captured function.
So now we'll see that we have
a parse_fn instance in addition
to just parse_fn
CapturedFunction object.
And similarly, we create a
Shuffle Iterator, and finally,
the TFRecord Iterator.
And because TFRecord
Data set has no inputs,
this is where the recursive
creation of the input pipeline
state stops.
And the control bubbles up
back to IteratorResource, that
returns a resource handle--
actually, MakeIterator() doesn't
return a resource handle.
We already have the
resource handle.
AUDIENCE: Question.
YURI: Uh-huh?
AUDIENCE: Does the input
pipeline have to be a line?
Or can it be a DAG?
YURI: So at the data set
level, the input pipeline
can be a DAG.
At the iterator
level, it will always
be a tree, if that makes sense.
OK.
So next, let's take
a look at next().
So when the IteratorGetNextOp is
invoked because we're starting
to iterate through the
elements of the input pipeline,
we again look up the resource
using to LookupResource()
method and then call
to GetNext() method
on the resource.
And as I mentioned
earlier, iterator resource
is thus the entry point to
the state of the iterator.
And what happens is this
recursively calls GetNext()
on the Batch Iterator.
And the Batch Iterator
says, well, I need
batch size worth of elements.
So let me get them one by one.
So it calls to Map Iterator to
say, please give me an element.
Map Iterator says,
well, I need an element
to apply a user-defined
function on.
So it's going to
ask Shuffle for one.
And Shuffle says, well, I need
a buffer size worth of elements
to do reasonable shuffling.
So it's going to call
to TFRecord Iterator.
And TFRecord Iterator will say,
OK, well, I have these files,
and I'm going to open and start
reading elements out of them.
So at this point, we
start returning data back
up this round trip between
Shuffle and TFRecord Iterators.
It might happen multiple
times initially.
And at some point, Shuffle
or has filled its buffer
off of elements
used for shuffling,
and produces a random element
back up to the Map Iterator,
which then applies the
user-defined function on it,
and takes its output,
and returns it back
to the Batch Iterator.
And this would be repeated
batch size number of times.
Then the Batch Iterator
would take all those elements
and create one higher-level,
higher-dimensional element out
of the individual
slices of the batch
and pass it on to
Iterator Resource.
And that would get created--
returned out to
the Python program.
Now finally, when the Python
iterator goes out of scope,
the Iterator
Resource is deleted.
And in a cascading fashion,
the other iterators
get created because their
ref count goes to 0,
or, we actually use
smart pointers that
are kind of connected between
the different iterator objects.
So far, so good?
Any questions?
OK.
So up to this point,
I talked primarily
about input pipeline that wasn't
trying to be performance-savvy.
And if it wasn't obvious
from the walkthrough
of the stages of
the iterator, it
seems like there's
a lot of steps
that would need to happen
to produce a single batch.
And if all these steps
lie on the critical path
of your computation, then
you're probably not executing
at the best possible
performance,
or at the peak of
your performance.
So we have a tf.data
performance guideline
that talks about
different mechanisms
to make sure that your input
pipeline is performant.
And the three main ones
are software pipelining,
processing parallelization,
and I/O parallelization.
And they all use various
performance artifacts,
either buffers or
parallelism, to allow
users to specify how their input
pipeline should be executed.
And in the context
of the parallelism--
and actually,
pre-fetching as well--
they all map down to
asynchronous threads
being started by the
data set of kernels.
And they are running
in the background,
disconnected from
the GetNext() calls,
generating values into
an internal buffer.
And when a GetNext()
call arrives,
it just waits until there
is something that buffer
and returns it.
So in the ideal case, there
is data in the buffer,
and you don't need
to wait at all.
But in case your
consumer of the data
is faster than
your producer, then
you might wait some of the
time, but hopefully not all
of the time.
So let's just take a look at how
this would change the diagram
that we talked about.
So what I did for the sake
of an illustration is I
added the
num_parallel_calls argument
to the map
transformation as well as
a prefetch transformation at the
very end of the input pipeline.
AUDIENCE: So you can prefetch
anywhere [INAUDIBLE]??
YURI: You can.
Yes.
Rule of thumb is that
the one at the very end
is usually the one that you
get the most mileage out
of because it allows you
to overlap the computation
the entire pipeline with
the computation that
might be happening in the
model, either on [INAUDIBLE]..
But yes, in theory--
I have a pertinent
quiz later on.
We'll see that prefetching
or decoupling the producer
and consumer anywhere
throughout you input pipeline
might be a good idea.
So the changes that reflect
what happened, or changes
in the pipeline code map
to the following changes
in the diagram.
We now have a Prefetch
Iterator and Prefetch Data Set
at the end of the pipeline.
And we also have a ParallelMap
Iterator and ParallelMap
data set, instead of just
regular Map Iterator, Map Data
Set.
It turns out with tf.data,
we have a different op kernel
from the one that
uses parallelism.
AUDIENCE: Do you support
Racket tensors yet?
YURI: No.
But the CL that introduces
that support on--
actually a couple of CLs--
but we're very close.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
And do you see any
performance decreases
when using Racket tensors?
YURI: So because we are
not supporting them yet,
I don't have a good
answer to that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
YURI: I think, through the
course of the review process
for bringing that
support in, we've
been cognizant of making sure
that the implementation is
efficient so that it works
well out of the gate.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But you support sparse tensors?
YURI: We do.
AUDIENCE: OK.
YURI: Yeah.
So the hope is that
the programs that
use sparse tensors that also
use Racket tensors will see
a performance boost
by switching to Racket
tensors once that
support is rolled up.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
Thank you.
YURI: Mhm.
And so the runner
threads that are our
illustrated here, these are
the background threads that
decouple the producer and
consumer in the Prefetch
Iterator and the ParallelMap
Iterator respectively.
And they're actually not started
until the very first getNext
invocation.
So before you call getNext
for the first time,
the iterator is idle.
There's no activity happening.
But the moment you
start fetching data out
of the iterator, background
threads might be started
or thread pools might be
created that might start
performing a background entity.
An interesting, exciting thing,
or a consequence of this,
is that a traditional
way to look
at the performance of TensorFlow
would be a timeline, which
gives you a view
into what happens
in the context of
a single stack.
And this particular
abstraction doesn't match well
with the asynchronous
nature of tf.data execution.
In addition to
that, you will only
see the iterator get mixed up,
which might not necessarily
give you a good view
into what's actually
happening at the different
stages of the tf.data
into pipeline.
And so at the recent
Dev Summit, we
announced that there is
going to be an open source
version of a tool that we've
had available internally
for some time that
provides you with all
these details of information
so that you can debug
the performance of
your input pipeline
using the same tools
that we use internally.
OK.
So that concludes the section
where I talked about C++
and what happens in C++.
And there's a little
bit of a switch
now, because we're going
to go back to Python level
and talk about supporting
non-tensor types.
So tf.data supports more
than just regular tensors.
The different inputs
or outputs of your data
transformations can actually be
a number of different things--
sparse tensors,
tensor arrays, nests
of any of these optionals,
as well as nested data sets.
And here, I just illustrate it.
It's not an exhaustive
list, but I just
illustrate some of the
transformations in terms
of the types that
they support either
as an input or an output.
AUDIENCE: What
about NumPy arrays?
YURI: NumPy arrays
are supported as well.
They kind of fall into the
category of tensors by virtue
being of trivially
convertible to tensors.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
YURI: Similar to NumPy,
there's something
called SparseTensorValue,
which is really
just a Python
namedtuple return type.
And that's kind of the NumPy
equivalent for sparse tensors.
And I think Racket
tensors have the same.
They have a Racket tensor value.
AUDIENCE: With the caveat
in [INAUDIBLE] and in eager,
you don't actually
need the value types
because you can have a sparse
tensor or a Racket tensor whose
values are eager tensors,
which are trivially
convertible to NumPy arrays.
YURI: Yeah.
Yeah.
So the value type is an
artifact of graph mode 1.x.
So the mechanism that
tf.data uses under the hoods
could provide support
for these different types
is the tf.data structure
API, which is this interface
and will require any type
to be supported in tf.data
to implement this interface.
I'm not going to talk
about each of these,
but the list of methods
is neither short nor long.
So for example, the
support for TensorArray
was introduced less
than a month ago.
And it was one day of work.
So I don't think that the
overhead of introducing
the support for the
type, as long as it's
kind of natural how to implement
this method is very large.
Having said that, the
support for Racket tensor
has been in the
works for some time.
And part of it is
because we actually
want that implementation
to be very performant.
And so it prompted creation of
new C++ kernels to make sure
that the performance is
good from the get-go.
Instead of talking
about the individual
methods in the interface,
what I want to do here
is I want to illustrate how
this interface is actually
used to provide the
polymorphism at the Python level
for different types of
tf.data transformations.
So for instance, if we look
at the tf.data data set
from tensors transformation,
which is a data source that
just take a memory array and use
it as a data set source, what
the implementation at the Python
level does is it computes,
or it involves the structure
from value methods,
to compute an instance of the
structure object and stores
internally in its attribute.
And then it passes the output
of structure to tensor arrays,
to the op kernel--
so the tensor data
set op kernel.
I forgot to mention
earlier, at the C++ level,
tf.data only deals with
flat lists of tensors.
And so we need a mechanism to
go between that representation
and the Python numTensor
nested structure
of also arbitrary types.
And it's the to_tensor_list
and from_tensor_list
that provide us with this boxing
and unboxing, if you will,
between the two representations.
from_tensor_slices is similar.
The difference
between from_tensors
and from_tensor_slices
is that instead
of viewing data as a single
tensor, we end up slicing it.
We assume that the value
has a rank of at least 1.
And we end up slicing it
into however many slices
it has in the dimension.
And these are the invocations
of the structure API
that would allow us to do
this kind of agnostically
to the actual type
of the Python value.
I also want to illustrate
how the structure
API is used in the context
of user defined functions.
In particular, the function
that we end up tracing
is actually a different function
than just the function the user
process.
We end up wrapping
the function that
gets passed in the Python
program in invocations
to from_tensor_list and
then to_tensor_list.
And this is kind
of the glue that I
talked about where we make sure
that the Python record expects
a flat list of tensors.
And then we reconstruct the
structure and the typing,
using the from_tensor_list
invocation,
because that's what user
provided function expects.
And then we again deconstruct
the structure and box
all the known tensor
types and tensors,
because that's what the upstream
transformation of tf.data
expects.
All right.
So next up, let's talk
about static optimizations,
which illustrates that
everything that I talked
about up to this point
about how tf.data works
is only part of the truth.
So in tf.data, we have a number
of transformations or a number
of optimizations implemented.
Here is a subset of
the ones who we have.
And the ones that
are in italics are
the ones that
enabled by default.
And the ones that
are not italic,
then those can be enabled
through tf.data options.
This is how you
would, for example,
go about enabling a map
vectorization transformation
if you wanted to.
The tf.data options
has other features.
It's not just for optimizations,
it is also, for example,
for specifying threading or
statistics collection features.
But in the context of
static optimizations,
I'm just illustrating
how it's used for those.
So what happens at the Python
level when iterator is created
is that the data set Python
object has an options
object associated with it.
And we use the
information in the options
object to possibly chain
additional data set
transformations on the
end of the data set.
This is something that the
user doesn't see in their code,
doesn't write in their code.
It's something that we
do at the Python level
to allow us to
insert functionality
that we would like to insert.
And one of the main uses of
this is this optimized data set
that's used as an entry point
for any static optimizations
that are to be applied
to the input pipeline.
So if we take a look
at the C++ level,
what's happening inside of the
optimized data set kernel is
we'll again get the
input of the data set,
and then invoke a data
set optimized method
on the optimized
data set kernel.
And the code is
actually quite long,
so I just summarized it in
high level statements here.
This is what happens inside
of the optimized method.
We first use the AsGraphDef
functionality to go from
the C++ representation of
the input object to GraphDef
representation of
the input object.
We then use Grappler to
apply the subset of tf.data
optimizations that are
either enabled by default,
or explicitly enabled
by a user, which
will give us a transformed
GraphDef representing the data
set.
And we then convert the
rewritten GraphDef to a C++
representation
using GraphRunner.
And finally, we update
the input with the result.
So because map and
batch optimization
is one of the optimizations
enabled by default,
the map and batch stages
that were in our example
would be, in fact, replaced
with a single map and batch data
set, which is a more performant
version of diffused map
and batch transformation.
And last topic that
I want to talk about
are dynamic optimizations.
So I mentioned before
that users have
a number of mechanisms to make
their input pipelines more
performant.
They can insert prefetching
with buffer_size.
They can insert map
with num_parallel_calls
or interleave with
num_parallel_calls
to apply various performance
optimization tools.
But what are good values
of these arguments,
like buffer_size and
num_parallel_calls?
Well, so in the context
of this section,
I'm only going to focus on
the parallelism optimization.
And to get you interested,
I have a quiz for you.
[LAUGHTER]
So imagine that
you have an input
pipeline that looks like this.
It reads from a set
of files, and then it
applies two transformations.
And on the right-hand
side in the comment,
I mentioned how much
time is required
to get a single element,
assuming constant processing
time through the particular
stage of the input pipeline.
So with this information,
how much time do you
think you would need,
when you call getNext,
how long would it take to
get a single element out?
AUDIENCE: 200 milliseconds.
YURI: 320.
AUDIENCE: 320.
YURI: 320 is the answer,
because everything
executes sequentially.
So when you call into
the outermost map,
that goes recursively
into the innermost
or the inner map,
which calls recursively
into the tf record data set.
We spend 20 milliseconds
there, then we
spend 100 milliseconds in the
inner map executing f, and then
200 milliseconds in the
order map executing g.
So it's 320.
I think you kind of jumped
one step ahead here.
[LAUGHTER]
And this was supposed
to be a trick question,
but you already got the answer.
What happens here if we
just add num_parallel_calls
to the map transformations?
Nothing, except
something happens.
And the reason for this
being 200 milliseconds
is that num_parallel_calls uses
a different op kernel which
has a background thread that
will be performing activity
independently of the
consumer of the data.
So the very first element will
actually take 320 milliseconds.
But then over time,
there is going
to be the processing done for
the three different stages will
be actually overlapped because
there is now two background
threads doing
everything in parallel.
The parallelism is
1 at each stage,
but that still gives
you 200 milliseconds,
in total, in the stable
state, assuming--
AUDIENCE: Is that the
correct mental model to think
that this implies prefetch?
YURI: Yes.
That a very good mental model.
Parallel map is, in
fact, the prefetching
by the virtue of using
a background thread.
And so in a way, this is
an answer to your question
where prefetching
inside of the input
pipeline, not just at the very
end, might provide benefits.
AUDIENCE: Question.
So does that imply that the
map function has to be traced?
Like, for example, if the
map function is just a Python
function, and if you
have multi-threading
on Python function,
then really [INAUDIBLE]??
YURI: So I think the
answer is that you
will get these benefits,
irrespective of the cost,
the constant cost of
the Python function is--
of the function passed into
the map transformation.
If it's implemented
as a py_func,
that function itself might be--
oh, I see what you're saying,
that multiple functions would
be escaping into Python.
That's a good point.
Possibly.
I would want to convince
myself that they actually
are all content for
the same [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Either way.
AUDIENCE: If you
ever use Python,
you need to make sure your
Python is thread safe.
It's very hard for
a TensorFlow runtime
to not accidentally run
Python code from many threads
at the same time.
YURI: Yeah.
I think the bottom line
here is that if you
can avoid using py_func,
for instance, use autograph.
So it perhaps might
not be surprising
that if you increase the
values of num_parallel_calls,
because you know
how much time you're
going to spend in
each of those stages,
you can get to the optimal
output latency of this input
pipeline.
You cannot run any faster than
the slowest part of the input
pipeline, which in this case is
the sequential TFRecordReader.
There might actually be a way
to speed this up even further,
by using interleave,
num_parallel_calls
over the different readers.
But instead of exploring that
avenue, what I want to ask
is, what do you
think happens here?
AUDIENCE: Dismal performance.
YURI: Yeah.
I think the answer
is, it depends.
It might actually run
well, well enough,
because
num_parallel_calls doesn't
mean that you create that
many threads, at least
in the case of map
transformation anyhow.
It means that you allow
to schedule as many ops
into the interop thread
pool at the same time.
And because you're allowed to
schedule them at the same time,
you need a place to store them.
So if nothing else, the
downside of specifying
a very large value
of num_parallel_calls
is that you're going to
use more memory to store
these intermediate values
than you would actually
need for equal
performance, which
might hurt your temporal
locality or thread locality.
So yes, the performance
might actually become worse,
but the reasons for
why can be subtle and
environment-specific.
AUDIENCE: You said earlier that
ops create their own threads.
Is that actually the case?
Or do they use the shared
thread pools in the executor?
YURI: They create
their own thread.
Parallel map, prefetch end
up creating their own thread.
Parallel interleave creates
its own thread pool.
Under the hoods, they end
up using this abstraction
of an unbounded thread pool,
if you are familiar with that,
which was introduced recently
to combat memory fragmentation
issues in the open
source memory allocator,
resulting from excessive
thread creation.
So the unbounded thread pool
that the tf.data uses creates
this illusion of logical threads
that are mapped onto a smaller
subset of physical threads.
But they're different from
the inter_op thread pools
or any of the core TensorFlow
runtime thread pools.
We do rely in tf.data data
on the inter_op thread
pool for the execution of
the user-defined functions,
by default. But there is also
an option to override that.
And we also, by
default, take advantage
or inherit the setting of
the inter_op_parallelism.
And there is also a way
to override that just
for the tf.data ops.
And as a matter of
fact, our experience
has been that disabling
inter_op_parallelism for--
and this is perhaps
not a surprise to you,
but disabling
inter_op_parallelism
altogether for CPU
content input pipelines
gives you 10%, 20% speed up.
Because you don't need to
parallelize the individual ops,
you get the parallelism by
running multiple of them
in parallel.
AUDIENCE: Do we have any
guides internally about how
you can do tricks
with tf.data to get
performance enhancements?
Or not so much?
YURI: Great question.
So instead of having
guides, why not
just have tf.data do
the hard work for you?
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
YURI: And so this is
something close to my heart
because I worked both on tf.data
performance in the early days
in terms of exposing
these knobs,
and then I worked very
hard on making sure
that users don't need to use
these knobs because there
is something that does a good
enough job automatically.
And you might think,
well, this seems
like a good fit for
reinforcement learning,
since we're in RMI.
And that's something that
I explored as an idea.
I didn't get it
to work, but that
might be because of me, not
because of reinforcement
learning.
[LAUGHTER]
The issue with reinforcement
learning-- so the idea is this.
What if you just pick some
values for the different paths
and knobs in your
input pipeline,
observed behavior, and then
try some different values
and use a smart algorithm
that kind of converges,
hopefully, to global optimum.
Well, it turns out that the
convergence was very slow.
And if you set abysmal
parameters for something
that could be
heavily parallelized,
then you would need
a very long time
to actually realize that
this is slow because
of poor parameters,
as opposed to this
is slow because that's how
fast the input pipeline runs.
So instead of
exploring reinforcement
learning that tries to modify
the parameters, or tf.data
has an analytical
model that models
the performance of
the input pipeline
that's currently instantiated.
And there's a little bit
of math in my presentation
because I'm originally a
formal verification person.
So here's some math for you.
You can model the
output latency of a node
as a function of the output
latencies of its inputs.
And the challenge
was, how do you
implement these two functions--
the processing time of a node,
as well as the lambda
function that captures
what the node itself does?
So the processing time is
modeled through a lightweight
instrumentation of the C++
implementation we have.
By lightweight,
I mean it imposes
roughly 100 nanoseconds of
overhead on the critical path.
And we keep track of
node creation, deletion,
as well as the computation,
the processing time,
spent within a node and
a user-defined function.
And the lambda, which is
the transformation-specific
functionality which maps how the
output latencies of the inputs
correspond to the output
latency of the op,
turns out there is a fairly
small number of categories
of node for each of which there
is a different type of lambda.
And the autotuning
mechanism then
takes advantage of these
two implementation artifacts
to tie it all together.
And we start a background thread
that periodically performs
the following optimization.
We snapshot the state of
the analytical model, which
captures the processing times
of the different iterators
that are currently
floating around.
And then we perform a very
simple hill-climbing algorithm
that allocates threads or
cores to parallelism knobs that
provide the greatest benefit.
So it's really algorithm,
assuming that this optimization
is actually monotonic.
And if you do that,
you can specify
AUTOTUNE for num_parallel_calls
in this example.
And as long as you
have 16 or more cores,
you get the same output
latency that you would get out
of the manually tuned one.
And the key is that it will
actually not over-provision
by an order of magnitude.
It might over-provision a
little bit, but not 1,024.
And that's it.
[APPLAUSE]